je vais jouer avec ça mon garçon alors
par exemple je suis sur les
commandements
[Musique]
il sent bien briefé
iran
chouette mieux donc si moi je crois que
c'était du bidon
les bulls où les visiteurs noté avec
plaisir c'est du placo ça ouais ça c'est
du polystyrène ouais mais attention
c'est de la télé ça fait ça fait plus ou
pas regarde ça là ça sans son accord il
ya des traces de paria de la moquette
on voit là encore le chatterton c'est tu
es content d'être là bas et coutumes va
faire le tour du propriétaire pendant
qu'un cameraman qui décède alors tout ça
c'est à toi c'est un peu à moi ouais
ouais ça regarde ça d'une caméra qui
cache à ben oui derrière la caméra et à
françoise dubois france salue françoise
à françois se fait pas tape lui
demande-t-on visage bon nicolas je peux
demander à mon caméraman devenir aussi
j'ai toujours un cameraman qui me suis
dans ma vie pour pâques
après les oubliées comme ça je fais pas
ça des preuves de tout ça c'est laurent
a bah oui c'est la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission d'asie cp on embrasse sur la
bouche sur la bouche tout seul alors
avec la langue
elle va bien et je me les doigts de saab
maintenant ce sera plus facile et que
valérie maquilleuse ah ah non moi je
n'ai pas pris des capotes c'est l'ange
blanc tu peux te vas faire aussi mais
temps mais en fait c'est une énorme
partout où il ya peu après l'émission
adacore émission ça c'est la poubelle
voit l'annoncé de la courbe de dollars à
tête chez toi de là qu il faut pas
saladier de coke entier et c'est ainsi
le buffet est allé regarder rien regarde
comment bouffe bien au lavage ah c'est
bien parce que tous les deux on n'est
pas très grand et à la télé on fait plus
grand quizz et là c'est pratique parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on fait 1,96
tous les deux la gombe
quand les gens vont mais il est plus
petit c'est pour ça que c'est habillé en
noir s'est plus svelte merci le l'ange
blond c'est ça la l'ours blanc tiens ça
c'est ma loge regarde regarde la culture
hier 10 au dessus alors mesdames et
messieurs c'est une avant première pour
la première fois la loge de tirer
ardisson hollow la merde qu'est ce que
tu fous là je ne sais pas vrai avec des
styles que keynes et bon genre fait
répéter le blackjack fait déborder vous
le savez la vie est une tradition dans
cette émission c'est qu'à la fin de
chaque émission il ya le blind test
présenté par mme anciens fait partie
rock'n'roll
même si la peur tout ce qu'il a sur les
bras il avait sur la glace alors ça
dégueulasse aux mariés et 10 eric
zemmour et que c'est une personne telle
mémoire
bon alors là on continue la visite je
vais présenter un ami à moi ah je
connaissais pas du tout que j'ai
découvert qu'un mec vachement sympa mais
il a découvert normalement ça que j'ai
découvert quand il est venu faire
l'émission
ouais un type extraordinaire je tenais à
lundi c'est l'étape est d'amasser plus
de tout sort de cet homme c'est que j'ai
donné un indice le mec qui a écrit une
chanson très connue à chanson qu'il
adore et tu vas voir on va le voir il
est là tu vois là c'est le sud et au sud
me travail qui montrent que ces
émissions ici attend les siens
on est sur un autre plateau
voici et banquets oui
m
ça m'a pas paru si j'avais su j'aurais
pu aussi
[Applaudissements]
oui
la vis du showbiz
[Applaudissements]
les gens là
16 heures
après ça
[Applaudissements]
tél mittal ouais ouais
2,3 à vigo le blesse il dit
ah la la
ah là là là
appelée
je le fais
et
je ne suis à cayenne réseau
attention aux 2 3 way back et l'abattît
bien le mec était dans son école ouais
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça
avp plus
bossi
me tuer alors c'est pas
mais aussi
[Applaudissements]
et tu m'as volé non
m
il faut non
or monsieur attention
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter nous
allons faire maintenant
l'interview nul on ne bouge pas pendant
le djing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de trop bas fait si ce qu'est ce que
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu